So I'm supposed to find the shadow came from inside a daiquiri, are you sure we can't shave your head? Don't touch my head
Hey everybody its charlie pass the waffles because Legion is back
And we have the craziest of openers to talk about I got so many questions about this. What's going on. What are they implying?
It's not quite as confusing as it seems
They did a pretty good job of explaining
All that missing time at the very end of the episode if you are brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
All the Marvel videos there's gonna be a ton of Marvel dropping between infinity war and Deadpool in the next couple of months
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet also added bonus
There's ten episodes this season instead of eight like last season
So I'll try to explain what the video schedules gonna be at the end of this because as you could tell from crazy
Astral plane dance battles Legion is a very different kind of superhero show I wouldn't even call it a superhero show
So let's just start with the big stuff first
I'll go through my normal top 10
But there's way more stuff to talk about so I'll try to squeeze it all in
but starting with the big thing first that opening narration in the montage so you may have detected the
Familiar voice of the narrator sort of like a Rod Serling thing going on "there is a maze in the desert
carved from sand and rock a
Vast labyrinth of pathways and corridors", that's Jon Hamm from Mad Men the Creator was like I met him a little while ago
I needed someone to do these educational voiceovers as he calls them and Jon Hamm was like yeah sure of course
I'll do it so Jon Hamm is gonna be doing this throughout the season don't know how long they booked him for could be for
The entire season so we might get these Jon Hamm scenes where he explains concepts every single week
his voiceover is mostly talking about how David is still tied up with the shadow King on a
Psychic level like even though his body is elsewhere
They're still
communicating with each other on a certain level and because of that big WTF at the end we actually learned that he's helping him a
Little bit, but like the way they opened the episode talking about getting lost in the maze of your own mind
It's all about David
being this insane character from the comics that gets lost within the maze of his own mind as he goes deeper and
Deeper into the psychic realms in the astral plane, but it's also a nice way to talk about what's going on with Oliver's character
Too because you see him a couple times during the episode so the opening montage over that voice over where the camera pulls away
from Oliver in the pool
all the way
Out to him in present day you see the new actor playing a mall Farook sitting in a chair in what looks like Paris in
one of the levels of his mind
It's just a way to show you how the shadow king is in control of Oliver's body
And he's also keeping Lennie in these other personalities at bay the funny thing here though
Is what's going on with Lenny's character because technically Lennie is the Shadow King?
But it's another version of the Shadow King when he was still in David's mind
So don't drive yourself too crazy trying to figure everything out, but the big dance battle
So we got to talk about that and the club and what it represents
They actually found David's physical body in a club somewhere that looks like the club that they have that dance battle in
so there's like a psychic
Representation of the club that represents when he's talking and communicating with the Shadow King
So early in the episode the first time you see him try to follow this person who is the Shadow King like his true form
You see Lenny and Oliver stand up to block his way that's basically the Shadow King psychic
defenses
represented by these two characters trying to stop David from
Penetrating his mind in locating him like he says the Shadow King is hiding from me the fact that it's a dance battle is just
The director and the creator's way of visualizing their psychic battle because this is all happening in the astral plane
So if you wondered why they suddenly broke into song and dance and why all the lights started flashing behind them that is just them having
their full-blown wizard battle
but the real cool thing that they do this season is they let you know what the stakes are the goal by the end of
The season right away, so we have a very clear track to the finale Shadow King looking for his body
They need to stop him because of the shadow Kings consciousness rejoins with his body
He'll be unstoppable
We'll address the crazy twist at the end of the episode because that's all about what's going on with this new
Admiral character who I know everybody has a lot of questions about but they just want to show you how there's
Conflicts within the group and conflict between the characters outside of this overarching conflict with the shadow king
So shadow king is still the main villain of the season but within each characters arc
They have a conflict with another character like sid says you're keeping secrets from me
So there's even a conflict between the two of them because he's really trying to do what future Sid wants him to do
But present-day Sid doesn't know anything about that so she's really pissed off
But at the center of it you have David who's trying to defeat the Shadow King without killing Oliver
Which is what section Three is trying to do
They'll kill the Shadow King at any cost even if it means destroying all of her his body
Which is what
I think that
Post-credits scene and Sid from the future was talking about when she says you need to help him find his body
I think that's because they want to separate him from
Oliver's body so that they can fight the Shadow King and defeat him without having to kill Oliver
Because looping it back around to Oliver's wife who was doing all the drugs during the episode she looked completely off her rocker
And if you weren't sure what was going on with that crazy
bird-like creature that was wheeling past her that was another representation of what you could call this black goo creature the
delusion that Foster's in someone's mind
So she's got this full-blown delusion
It probably gets worse something
Terrible happens because Oliver probably ends up dying in this original version of the timeline so Sid from the future
Probably came back to tell David you need to help find a way to defeat the Shadow King that doesn't involve
Oliver dying so David is sort of caught between these two camps everybody in present-day
He wants to do the right thing fight the shadow king
But he also has to wrestle with the idea that he has to help the Shadow King because the current path that they're on
Only leads to something even worse, but hopefully that explains what that post-credit scene was about that was probably the biggest question
I got is like where was he for a year so the basic premise is that when he got sucked up into that sphere that
Was sent by Sid from the future he actually left the sphere went to help the shadow king
So when they say that Oliver had popped up and there were sightings all over the world in the past year
David was with him David can teleport the Shadow King cannot
So just a reminder they tried to tell you what everyone's abilities are and they had this big montage at the beginning of the episode
They sort of let you know
What was going on if you haven't watched the episodes in a while
But in the comics David has thousands of different powers on the TV show the only ones. We've seen so far is telepathy
telekinesis and
Teleportation so he has all the ultimate treasure hunter abilities
They can search people's minds to try and find traces of where the body might be and teleport
Instantaneously, but because his mind is so fragile and because he's operating with the Shadow King on so many different psychic levels
He's starting to get lost within the maze of his mind, so he's a very unreliable narrator, so if you're confused about the series
It's because it's being told largely from David's perspective, and he's not always sure what's going on
So that's why we as the audience as we watch things play out aren't totally sure what's going on
The set design was amazing we could talk all day about how amazing the series just
Looks the way that they film it the set design the costumes
And the way that they use that within episodes to tell you what's going on with the characters give you an idea for where their
Head spaces and make you feel disoriented like when David's talking to the Admiral
But he has the staircase behind him that sort of a visual
Metaphor for the staircase of his mind winding down deeper levels into his psyche
The best metaphor that I could give for the Admiral character is that he's kind of a Trask figure
Someone who's good wants to stop the villain, but really doesn't care about mutant kind
he said flat out that he's going to exterminate Oliver at any cost we need to do anything we can to stop the
Shadow king from getting his body of course. We have to mention the female mustaches
They're basically androids like part human part machine, but they have one psyche
That's all sort of linked collectively
He uses them to communicate probably as a defense mechanism
So that other people like David can't read his mind
The creator said the reason he wears that basket on his head is to show that he has no ego
There was an ancient Chinese general in the real world that wore one
So he's doing that to show that he's not an egotistical person
That's only in it for more power that pretty much covers most of it talking about Amahl Farouk though this character looks much more like
Comic book Amahl Farouk, I don't know about this actor here
He just seems like a more polished version of that character
So I think when they find his body by the end of the season this is what the body will actually look like
Even though he's inhabited so many different minds across the years remember he's from the 1800s
So he's been alive for a long time before Charles Xavier
trapped him on the astral plane
Talking a little bit more about the Professor X of it all
Patrick Stewart did say last year that he was totally game to come on the show
I don't know what plans they've made
They did say that they would push deeper into his origin
But just remember if we do see professor X on the TV show it will probably wind up being Patrick Stewart
I feel like that would be more rewarding to the fans than seeing James McAvoy in old man makeup
But the really big Easter Egg to Jon Hamm doing the voiceover for this series Jon Hamm was actually going to be mr.
Sinister during the New Mutants movie that's right. They were gonna do mr.
Sinister, but then there was a report that the Dark Phoenix movie separately from that was actually gonna do the mr.
Sinister character except that it was gonna be the female Mrs.
sinister gender bent character played by Jessica Chastain because she's gonna be the main villain of Dark, Phoenix
What'll probably happen is is because last season just Legion wasn't super popular on my channel
We'll see how this video does and at the very least I will do a video for
Every couple of episodes and definitely one for the finale like I did last season so no worries and the same thing is gonna happen
With Krypton, so I'm not going to be doing another Krypton episode video for a little while
But if they do something really big then I'll do a bonus video for that and I know there's still like a ton of
Legion questions like I only talked about brief parts of the episode so post all your questions in the comments below
But while you wait for everything click here for that brand new Deadpool cancer trailer and click here for brand new infinity war
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. We'll see you guys tonight